en este vídeo les voy a platicar un poco
de lo que es la distribución
cuadrada
la distribución sí cuadrada y en los
siguientes vídeos de hecho vamos a
usarla para para probar qué tan bien que
también aproximan las distribuciones
teóricas o que también explican las
distribuciones observadas ok así que
vamos a pensar o sólo un poquito digamos
que tengo algunas variables aleatorias
cada una de ellas es independiente y
tiene una distribución normal estándar
ok tenemos
digamos esta variable aleatoria x que se
distribuye de forma normal con media 0 y
desviación estándar 1
o varianza igual a 1 es decir la
esperanza de x es igual a cero y la
varianza de x es igual a 1 o para
visualizarlo digamos si vamos a tomar
una muestra cuando tomamos
en la gráfica de la distribución es de
esta forma verdad se ve así la media es
de 0 la desviación estándar es de 1 la
varianza es 1
este sigma o sigma cuadrada ok que es la
varianza o la desviación estándar y
baleón así que una distribución he
cuadrada cuando tomamos una de estas
variables aleatorias digamos que tenemos
varias pero tomamos una déjenme
definirlas y digamos que esta es la
variable q
vamos a ponerlo con otro color y esta va
a ser esencialmente tomar muestras de
esta desviación perdón de esta
distribución estándar normal ajá y le
elevamos al cuadrado así que esto es
igual a equis cuadrada
ok esto va a ser igual a equis cuadrada
así que la distribución de esta variable
aleatoria aquí va a ser un ejemplo un
ejemplo de las distribuciones y
cuadradas de hecho lo que vamos a ver en
este vídeo es que la he cuadrada la
distribución es un conjunto de
distribuciones que dependen de cuántos
sumandos tienes aquí por ejemplo sólo
tenemos uno y estamos elevando al
cuadrado así que este es uno de los
ejemplos muy bien vamos a hablar un
poquito más de ello en unos segundos
aunque ya sí que podríamos escribir que
la q tiene una distribución cuadrada que
la anotación que usamos así digamos
tomamos la letra griega y que es como
una equis curva dita verdad pero es un
miembro de las distribuciones y
cuadradas y como sólo tomamos un sumando
entonces vamos a decir que tiene una
bueno tomamos un sumando de una que
tiene distribución normal estándar así
que como sólo tomamos 1 decimos que
tiene un grado de libertad así que este
es un grado de libertad
muy bien ahora vamos a definir digamos
si este de la q no vamos a definir otra
variable aleatoria vamos a llamarle q o
que dejen de hacerlo con otro color
vamos a llamarle q 2 es un azul este
escudo entonces vamos a definir lo que
tenemos una primera variable aleatoria
con distribución normal aunque que vamos
a llamar x 1 y lo elevamos al cuadrado
luego tenemos otra independiente de
distribución normal estándar y ya sabes
este pues vamos a sumar le vamos a sumar
la baja y elevamos al cuadrado así que
puedes imaginar que estos 22 tipos
tienen esta distribución como esta y son
ambas independientes así que para
obtener q2 esencialmente tomamos una
muestra de x1 de la distribución
cuadrada y luego de x2 en la misma
distribución esencial esencialmente y
luego lo elevamos al cuadrado y sumamos
los valores ok
así que digamos si éste era con 12 aquí
vamos a escribir que q 2 tiene una
distribución y cuadrada con dos grados
de libertad
aquí esto es lo que le llamamos dos
grados de libertad y justamente para
visualizar este conjunto de
distribuciones y cuadradas tengo esta
esta esto de aquí esto lo saqué de la
wikipedia y esto nos muestra algunas de
las densidades de probabilidad de las
funciones para algunas desde
distribuciones y cuadradas la primera de
aquí es para cuando tenemos un grado de
libertad es decir tenemos solo un
sumando esto es para q 1 así que la
función para q no quiero que noten que
hace como un pico cerca del cero verdad
y eso tiene sentido porque si tomamos
una muestra de esta distribución normal
estándar ahí hay un año hay un gran
chance de que si estamos cercanos al
cero entonces cuando elevamos al
cuadrado algo cercano a cero como es muy
muy pequeño de hecho es menor que uno se
va a aparecer cada vez más a cero así
que por eso tenemos una alta
probabilidad de obtener valores pequeños
digamos hasta cierto umbral digamos y
aquí está el 1
y aquí está el uno digamos a castelo en
medio bueno vamos a tener una baja
probabilidad de obtener un número grande
por ejemplo si queremos un 4 necesitamos
que en la muestra salga un 2 y entonces
sabemos que realmente está alejado de la
varianza el son de hecho dos
desviaciones estándar y bueno para
obtener un 4 que es un número bastante
grande es poco probable de obtenerlo ya
que es difícil de obtener un 2 verdad
así que de ahí que sale esta esta forma
ahora si tenemos 2 grados de libertad
digamos que es esta es esta forma de
esta línea azul la forma de q2 batman
vamos a notar que es un poquito distinta
porque porque todavía es como como una
todavía los números pequeños son tienen
una mayor probabilidad de ser obtenido
pero si tenemos digamos ahora la la q3
otra variable aleatoria que vamos a
definirla como la suma de tres variables
aleatorias independientes elevada al
cuadrado esto es x1 al cuadrado más x2
al cuadrado más x 3 al cuadrado todas
son independientes con de distribución
normal estándar entonces q3 decimos que
tiene distribución cuadrada con tres
grados de libertad
tenemos este de color amarillo vuelven a
la curva va a ser la verde
así que tenemos como una línea que
obtiene hasta cierto rango digamos como
estamos tomando la suma entonces empieza
a moverse hacia la derecha así que
mientras más grados de libertad tenemos
lo más lejano que esté brinco este
brinco este máximo obtenemos no y más
simétrico es cómo lo vamos obteniendo y
es interesante porque es muy distinta a
todas las funciones que hemos encontrado
verdad y digo tenemos muy poco muy poca
probabilidad de obtener un cero porque
todos estos son positivos tienen
distribución normal pero bueno como
estamos elevando al cuadrado y tomando
sumas esto siempre va a ser positivo y
el lugar es de lo que vamos a hacer en
los siguientes vídeos es medir
esencialmente el error de una esperanza
de un valor esperado y si tomamos el
error total podemos figurar la
probabilidad de obtener ese error de
bueno si obtenemos ciertos parámetros o
si suponemos que tenemos ciertos
parámetros
vamos a utilizar esta tabla de la
distribución de he cuadrada así que lo
que voy a pedirles o lo que yo les
pediría es que de esta distribución
digamos que si tenemos dos grados de
libertad de agregar dos variables si yo
les pregunto la probabilidad cuál es la
probabilidad de q 2 de ser mayor que y
déjenme pensar
déjenme ponerlo de esta forma cuál es la
probabilidad de que q2 sea más grande
que 2.41 estoy agarrando este valor por
una razón y estamos haciendo un caso
práctico de cómo hacer esta este cálculo
entonces lo que quiero hacer es fijarme
en esta tabla de la ji cuadrada q 2 es
una versión de ji cuadrada con dos
grados de libertad así que si me fijo en
este renglón que es el de dos grados de
libertad y yo quiero la probabilidad de
obtener un valor un valor arriba de 2.41
muy la mayoría de estas tablas de la ji
cuadrada
en realidad es un bonche de números
raros pero en realidad es la
probabilidad de que obtengamos cierto
valor mayor que ese valor de hecho así
que digamos si yo quiero decir cuál es
el valor de la he cuadrado para dos
grados de libertad para el cual yo tengo
que la probabilidad es mayor que 241
2.41 entonces diremos que es 30% así que
la probabilidad de que la q2 sea mayor
que 2.41 o su valor p
es 30% y está aquí en la tabla es este
30% así que esta distribución sí
cuadrada digamos vamos a verlo en la
gráfica si aquí anda el 2.41 digamos en
este puntito en realidad estamos la
tabla nos está diciendo que esta área el
área debajo de esta curva azulita
estaré aquí que es bueno el área es 30%
3.3 realmente punto 3 es más correcto
decirlo así así que el área de debajo de
esa curva después del 2.41 es punto 3
que es el 30 por ciento del área debajo
de la curva azul en el próximo vídeo
vamos a usar esta distribución para
usarlo sobre algunas pruebas de
inferencia